bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de rente hebdo nous sommes au
coeur du parlement européen à strasbourg
oui katia elle dans cette édition
direction la pologne c'est un des
premiers pays européens à exploiter ces
gaz de schiste est ici au parlement le
débat fait rage
et d'abord l'actualité dominée par la
situation à gaza et en israël que fait
l'union européenne pour le proche orient
c'est la question de la semaine
à gaza les années se suivent et se
ressemblent 2008 plomb durci 2012
pilier de la défense il sera l 3 mas
bombe contre roquettes sécurité contre
survie et comme toujours à la clé des
centaines de morts dont des femmes et
des enfants
c'est aussi l'éternel retour du ballet
diplomatique les délégations se suivent
et se ressemblent egypte onu france
turquie qatar objectif obtenir une trêve
un cessez-le-feu stopper cette fameuse
escalade de la violence
pendant ce temps en europe face à
l'urgence on se réunit et surprise on ma
gauche
d'un communiqué dans lequel l'union
demande un cessez le feu il mais bien un
peu court non alors que fait l'union
pour les prochains lyon et la violences
redoublent au proche-orient ce mercredi
21 novembre nouvel attentat en plein
coeur de tel aviv une actualité
internationale chargée pour en parler
un député européen est avec nous arnaud
danjean bonjour alors vous êtes membre
du parti populaire européen vous siéger
à la commission des affaires étrangères
et vous êtes responsable vous vous êtes
rapporteur sur la politique de défense
européenne dont vous connaissez bien
cette question est-ce que selon vous
l'europe peut faire quelque chose face à
l' escalade au proche-orient ou est-ce
qu'au contraire elle est totalement
impuissante
non l'europe est pas totalement
impuissante et c'est un peu un raccourci
de dire que l'europe ne peut faire que
des communiqués c'est la version
effectivement visible immédiate de
l'action immodeste diplomatiquement il
ya quand même beaucoup de négociations
en coulisse et quand on mentionne les
visites de tel ou tel ministre des
affaires étrangères d'un pays européen
son action est coordonnée avec celle de
la haute représentante kathy ashton et
les coordonnées avec celles des 26
autres pays
donc il ya une activité diplomatique
intense c'est vrai que pour le grand
public tout ça n'est pas très
spectaculaire tout ça ne se voit pas
beaucoup et on a l'impression d'une
impuissance générale
mais l'europe j'allais dire n'est pas
plus impuissante que malheureusement
d'autres acteurs qui essayent aussi eu
de mettre un terme à cette escalade de
la violence
mais concrètement vous êtes député
européen le parlement européen condamne
les violences dans une résolution mais
est-ce que à part condamné regretté il
n'y a pas quelque chose de plus à faire
en utilisant notamment par exemple les
des sanctions économiques
non seulement il savait qu'on l'europe à
une action économique assez forte dans
la région au proche orient auprès de
l'autorité palestinienne la situation de
gaza est malheureusement très spécifique
puisque c'est une enclave tenue par le
hamas avec lequel les relations sont
impossibles du fait des positions
extrême que tient le hamas vis-à-vis
d'israël et ensuite vous avez
effectivement cette escalade de la
violence dont on espère qu'elle sera
ponctuelle mais qui est toujours trop
évidemment l'europe a tenté de faire des
choses l'europe avait par exemple monter
une mission pour le point frontière
entre l'egypte et gaza pour essayer de
contrôler les biens qui transitent par
ces points frontière donc ce avec les
israéliens sont sont très sont très
sensibles puisque beaucoup d'armes ont
transité aussi cette mission n'est plus
possible dans le contexte actuel mais
pourquoi pas un jour où l'autre l'europe
comme facilitateur des changes
commerciaux pour subvenir aux besoins de
la population par exemple
donc ce sont évidemment des exemples
très modeste mais l'europe est déjà
présente
elle pourrait sans doute l'être un peu
plus ça dépend aussi de la volonté des
deux parties et en l'occurrence je ne
suis pas certain que les deux parties
soient forcément très désireuse d'avoir
l'europe comme un interlocuteur un peu
plus un peu plus puissant sur place il
ya un représentant qui travaille aux
côtés de madame ashton est ce que lui
qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est vrai vous
savez l'équation l'équation du conflit
israélo palestinien elle est à la fois
très simple et quasi insoluble tous les
paramètres sont sur la table on sait
très bien quelles sont les choses qui
bloque pour parvenir à des accords mais
personne n'a la baguette magique pour
débloquer ces choses là
alors évidemment tout ça est extrêmement
frustrant mais je crois qu'il faut pas
pour autant minimiser les efforts qui
sont qui sont qui sont faits encore une
fois les résultats sont pas forcément
spectaculaire on ne peut pas non plus se
substituer aux parties elles-mêmes
on peut les inciter on peut les
encourager on peut les sanctionner le
cas échéant ne peut pas se substituer
aux parties elles mêmes
l'idée d'une force d'interposition avait
été évoquée est ce que ça pourrait être
une solution selon vous c'est un sujet
qui revient régulièrement pour avoir une
force d'interposition il faut d'abord
l'accord des deux parties c'est là
encore on revient toujours à ce même
problème il faut l'accord des deux
parties
et puis il faut avoir des pays qui sont
prêts à contribuer or compte tenu de la
complexité
de la situation de la dangerosité de la
situation c'est vrai on a déjà des
forces d'interposition au sud liban
on pourrait un jour envisager d'en avoir
entre une autorité palestinienne ou gaza
même et les israéliens elles peuvent
être efficace parfois ses forces ont
lavé dans sa oui ils peuvent être
efficaces mais leur efficacité dépend
aussi beaucoup de la bonne volonté des
deux parties de jouer le jeu je ne suis
pas sûr que ce paramètre existe
actuellement entre israël et la
palestine
alors il ya la situation au proche
orient il ya aussi la situation en syrie
au congo au mali est ce que sur tous les
théâtres de conflits l'europe peut faire
quelque chose et parle notamment du mali
il ya un otage français qui a été fait
ou un otage français au mali est ce que
le ce contexte de durcissement rend
toujours possible éventuelle
intervention européenne sur ce théâtre
là oui j'ai d'ailleurs l'europe a pris
des décisions là encore sans doute des
décisions qui apparaîtront trop modeste
et peut-être un peu tardive mais en tout
cas l'europe a pris des décisions celle
d'envoyer une mission de formation
auprès des forces de sécurité maliennes
dont on sait qu'elles seront en première
position si une intervention militaire a
lieu la position européenne est assez
clair si intervention militaire il y à
elle doit être conduite par des
africains mais avec un soutien européen
c'est un soutien qui peut être
logistique un soutien en formation c'est
ce que l'union européenne a décidé donc
c'est quelque chose qui va se mettre en
place
on peut regretter et je les fais à titre
au titre de la sous commission de la
défense du parlement européen on peut
regretter que ça intervienne sans doute
un peu tard avec l'union européenne
avait pensé réfléchi à cette stratégie
sur le sahel depuis longtemps depuis
mars avril 2011 des conclusions avaient
été faites au niveau du conseil européen
malheureusement nous les mettons en
oeuvre que maintenant un an et demi
après c'est un peu long et le fait qu'il
ait un otage français au mali ça ne
remet pas en cause tout les tous et
préparer la peau pital al adha le fait
qu'ils aient des otages français puisque
avec le nouvel os cage dont on a appris
récemment la la capture ça fait
maintenant huit otages français
évidemment été légèrement évidemment ça
complique les choses
évidemment ça peu inhibés par rapport à
des interventions militaires mais encore
une fois j'allais dire le processus est
en marche mais le processus est en
marche aussi avec une médiation
diplomatique si on arrive à trouver une
solution politique il faudra bien de
toute façon un accord politique avant ou
après une intervention militaire
on privilégie privilégiera pardon cette
option là mais il faut être prêt à toute
éventualité
vous dites que on aurait pu aller plus
vite
oui ce front là vous le regrettez oui je
regrette beaucoup parce que les éléments
étaient connus depuis longtemps on sait
que cette zone du sahel est une zone
instable
malheureusement tous les états européens
ne sont pas sensibilisés de la même
façon ça paraît une évidence pour nous
français qui sommes confrontés au
problème des otages c'est beaucoup moins
évident quand vous êtes polonais baltes
slovaque de considérer que le mali est
une priorité stratégique pour l'union
européenne et donc c'est ce travail de
conviction qui a pris beaucoup de temps
auprès de tous nos partenaires et pour
vous c'est une priorité stratégique moi
c'est une priorité par ce qui se passe
dans le sahel
au delà même du mali il se passe dans
cette région du sahel qui est très
proche
il se passe si vous voulez la la
synthèse du terrorisme de la criminalité
organisée des problèmes migratoires des
problèmes de développement c'est donc
une zone explosive alors la sécurité
n'est pas la seule réponse mais en tout
cas sans sécurité on ne pourra pas avoir
des politiques de développement efficace
dans cette région alors une dernière
question peut-être sur la syrie est ce
que vous pensez que l'union européenne
peut et doit reconnaître l'opposition
syrienne qui vient tout juste de se
constituer dans l'union européenne en
début de semaine franchi un premier pas
en considérant en considérant que la
nouvelle coalition nationale syrienne
est une voie légitime et contrairement à
la france et à l'angleterre
l'union européenne dans sa globalité n'a
pas reconnu comme la seule autorité
légitime ce nouveau conseil cette
nouvelle coalition nationale c'est une
question extrêmement compliqué
il faut se méfier quand même on a quand
même à faire à une coalition qui est
très hétéroclite la représentativité la
représentativité est quand même encore
mal établies
on n'est pas exactement dans la même
configuration la libye c'est un cas la
sir est un cas beaucoup plus compliqué
que que la libye et c'est ce qui ce qui
rend évidemment toute solution
là aussi beaucoup plus aléatoire merci
beaucoup
arnaud danjean d'avoir été avec nous
alors l'actualité c'est aussi la
bataille du budget européen qui bat son
plein un pays s'illustre le royaume uni
qui refusent d'augmenter sa contribution
à ce budget du coup les médias européens
s'interrogent les britanniques ont-ils
toujours leur place dans l'union
européenne
réponse avec ce tour d'horizon des télés
européennes signent et aurélie d'afas
dans les années 70 la grande-bretagne
voter massivement pour rejoindre la
communauté européenne
trente six ans plus tard les journaux et
les politiciens conservateurs appellent
un référendum sur l'adhésion à l'ue à la
crise y est pour quelque chose
certainement mais pour beaucoup les
médias sont à blâmer une position c'est
pas raciste porté par les
libéraux-démocrates et qui agace en
allemagne qu'est ce qu'ils veulent les
britanniques alors ce n'est pas si
difficile à comprendre
ils veulent tous les avantages sans les
désavantages aujourd'hui plus que jamais
il n'y a pas d' européen convaincu
allons est l'un d'entre eux et le
libéral-démocrate nick clegg
quand vous inviter quelqu'un un dîner il
y a toujours la bonne vieille question
de qui paie l'addition camp david a reçu
en gala ce soir au 10 downing street
la question de l'addition a porté sur le
budget de l'union européenne pour 6 ans
3 milliards d'euros à quelques centimes
près et avec nos christophe garache
rédacteur en chef de rang par l'oti vdm
avants français
merci d'être avec nous alors comment
vous comprenez cette attitude de londres
et surtout est-ce que vous pensez que
les britanniques ont encore toujours
leur place en europe
première chose sur le budget une tous
les états membres dans l'union
connaissent une crise sans précédent
restrictions budgétaires austérité est
ce qu'on peut entendre le message d'un
chef d'état qui dit où la chef du
gouvernement qui dit écoutez moi j'ai
des problèmes dans mon pays chauds
obligé de couper les budgets partout
pouvais pas me demander d'augmenter le
budget européen il faut qu'je une
interconnexion enfin sinon les gens que
le puck mes électeurs vont pas
comprendre ça c'est la vision sans doute
qu'on peut et qu'on doit entendre la
vérité c'est que le budget de l'europe
c'est pas un budget de dépenses inutiles
ça budget globalement d'investissement
pourquoi pour le pour la halle pour
l'avenir pour les appeler pour les
réseaux d'infrastructure pour aider les
les régions en retard de développement à
développer donc il faut entendre ces
deux messages et puis dernier argument
c'est sûr c'est la crise aujourd'hui
mais ce qu'on doit geler pour les dix
prochaines années
un but le budget européen parce que
c'est la crise on sait pas ce qui va se
passer dans trois ans on espère que
d'ici trois ans on en sortira donc voilà
c'est tout ça qui font affaire autant d
visiblement le message ne passe pas long
c'est tout simple alors les britanniques
latitude et britanniques à gaz de plus
en plus de nombreux pays européens
l'allemagne
même la france à en croire les dernières
déclarations de françois hollande qui a
critiqué l'attitude de londres qui
s'accroche à son rabaisser ce qu'il a
dit en substance
et du coup on parle de plus en plus du
bri du bric site le bri existe ça veut
dire mettre la grande bretagne dehors
alors l'union européenne est ce que
c'est réaliste ou c'est complètement
elle est restée aujourd'hui les traités
européens ne le permettent le nouveau
traité lisbonne caen a eu tant de mal à
faire adopter permis aujourd'hui la
sécession un état membre n'est plus
poings pieds et poings liés advitam
eternam en europe s'il le veut quand il
le veut ça peut demander à sortir
d'union soit les britanniques pourraient
d'ici 2015 le demander ce droit
revendiqué ce droit à sortir de l'union
européenne et a renégocié son avenir
avec les européens ou sans les européens
eh ben on en reparlera dans quelques
temps merci beaucoup christophe garage
ou poursuit avec un focus sur les gaz de
schiste nous sommes allés voir comment
ça se passait en pologne pays où le
nombre de permis d'exploitation pour le
gaz de schiste augmente mais la
contestation elle aussi grossi regardez
ce reportage tourné près de varsovie par
paul bouffard
cette eau minérale a beaucoup de vertus
curatives
elle est utilisée depuis des siècles
pour guérir de nombreux maux est en
danger à cause des forages effectués
dans la région pour trouver du gaz de
schiste
roberts ne se prive pas de goûter l'eau
de son village une eau minérale réputé
en pologne
et pourtant la source est en sursis à
cause de l'exploitation du gaz de
schiste
d'ici quelques mois dans la région des
forages devraient voir le jour un drame
pour roberts son projet de rénover les
termes tomberait à l'eau
personne n'investira si des forages pour
extraire le gaz de schiste se font dans
un rayon de 10 km il y aura danger de
pollution pour les eaux salines le gaz
de schiste son exploitation nécessite
une fracturation hydraulique
les compagnies gazières injecte sous
pression un grand volume d'eau mêlées à
des produits chimiques dans la terre
laroche explose et libère le gaz
prisonnier les résidus d'eau peuvent
contaminer les nappes phréatiques
voisine et pour l'état polonais
impossible de passer à côté de cette
nouvelle source d'énergie
le gouvernement défend son nouvel
eldorado le gaz de schiste
c'est une chance pour la pologne mais
aussi pour l'union européenne
cette forme d'énergie peut jouer un rôle
important pour la relance de l'économie
polonaise mais aussi rendre la pologne
indépendante vis-à-vis des étrangers
le gouvernement espère profiter des
réserves importantes du pays pour
alimenter en gaz sa population pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années sans avoir
besoin d'eux
voisin russe jusqu'en 2022 la pologne
est lié par contrat avec le géant russe
de l'énergie gazprom qui leur fournit
près de la moitié de leur consommation
gazière
le gaz de schiste pourrait inverser la
tendance dont considérons avec beaucoup
de rigueur les angoisses des populations
et nous voulons lutter contre les mythes
liés au gaz de schiste
par exemple mon ministre le ministre du
trésor a bu en direct à la télévision
nationale le liquide que l'on injecte
pour la fracturation pour prouver que ce
n'est pas du poison varsovie compte
investir plus de 12 milliards d'euros
dans l'exploitation de ce gaz de schiste
alors on ouvre les portes à tous les
investisseurs et dans les campagnes
polonaise
on installe les forages comme ici la
gare ballin à deux heures de route de la
capitale selon la compagnie polonaise
d'énergie hors laine qui n'a pas
souhaité nous ouvrir officiellement les
portes du site
il n'y a aucun danger les rejets
polluants passeront dans un système
d'épuration heureux
et ce n'est pas la vie de cet homme
marek prix d'art à la tête de l'eau
alger polonaise aux pros il dénonce
cette exploitation du sol
selon lui le gouvernement a trop vite
oublier l'impact écologique
il y aura des centaines puis des
milliers de forage comme celui ci car
pour le gaz de schiste on a besoin de
beaucoup plus de forages que dans le cas
du gaz naturel et pour les habitants qui
sont dans le voisinage pour le tourisme
pour l'eau c'est un véritable danger
alors il ya du gan le forage va
s'installer
pas de commentaire c'est intéressant ça
on n'avait rien trouvé donc cet
engouement pour le gaz de schiste est
née d'une étude d'experts selon le
département américain de l'énergie
la pologne serait assise sur 5300
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz soit
300 ans d'indépendance gazière mais pour
andré yché schneck experts indépendants
la réalité est moins rose les américains
ont surévalué la richesse le gaz de
schiste pour l'instant pologne c'est
quelque chose de virtuel de très virtuel
c'est avant tout une affaire politique
mais pour l'instant il faut bien dire
que rien n'est rentable
regardez sur 31 forages effectués
actuellement il n'y en a aucun qui ait
véritablement exploitables alors le gaz
de schiste en pologne
on ne peut pas encore vraiment estimé
son coût d'exploitation peut-être 350
dollars pour mille mètres cubes
c'est en tout cas en tout cas ça reste
cinq fois plus cher que le gaz nature à
gaveau line marek rencontre les voisins
du forage et chez les agriculteurs
l'inquiétude monte
qu'allez vous faire si les exploite près
de vos chambres l'aurait déjà solide
c'est vrai elle est comment brunel
brunâtre alors vous la buvette
mais on boit l'eau municipale le puits
il est condamné inutile le piquant
depuis qu'ils ont commencé à forer je
sais pas ce que nous allons devenir
relancer l'économie se défaire de la
main russe selon un sondage 73 % des
polonais disent oui au gaz de schiste et
pour s'assurer le succès le gouvernement
distribue les permis d'exploitation pour
quelques dizaines de milliers de dollars
y compris sur des sites naturels
protégés
aucune règle n'encadre l'installation de
forage sur le sol polonais et voilà pour
ce reportage édifiant signé paul
bouffard et entre temps sur ce plateau
nous a rejoint josé bové merci d'être
avec nous on ne vous présente plus vous
êtes à la vie soit pas vous détenez la
vice-présidence pardon de la commission
sur l'agriculture et le développement
rural
vous connaissez bien la pologne à la
question des gaz de schiste voulzy vous
y est rendue plusieurs fois vous
connaissez marek notamment qui est dans
ce reportage
ce mercredi le moratoire que vous
demandiez sur le gaz de schiste a été
rejetée au parlement européen on voit en
pologne que la contestation est
embryonnaire finalement est ce que vous
avez perdu cette bataille à écouter non
je pense que pour l'instant quand on
réfléchit
cette bataille elle a commencé en france
qui a été un des premiers pays européens
où le combat est né en décembre 2010
aujourd'hui on est en novembre 2012
donc moins de deux ans après plusieurs
pays ont déjà mis des moratoires ont
interdit la mauvaise la technique de la
fracturation hydraulique qui est
dangereux celle qui peut risque de
polluer jours et c'est donc là c'est
déjà quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
on a un débat premier débat sur une
initiative parlementaire
donc en gros un voeu ce qu on a débattu
aujourd'hui au parlement européen c'est
un voeu
donc il ya eu un voeu sur des questions
environnementales nous on voulait qu'on
aille plus loin dans ce voeu qu on aille
jusqu au moratoire
ça n'a pas été acceptée mais dans ce
premier texte
l'ensemble des problèmes posés par jésus
six ont été bien montrer démontrer
à partir de là ce que j'espère c'est que
la commission européenne elle va se
saisir des demandes du parlement
européen pour mettre en cohérence
la législation européenne avec la
question du gaz de schiste dont vous
voulez une législation carrément
sur la question alors il n'y aura pas
une législation parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'au niveau européen
l'énergie n'est pas une compétence
européenne chaque état fait ce qu'il
veut je dirais parfois ça peut être bien
parfois et souvent ça peut être
catastrophique
la france avec le nucléaire la pologne
avec le gaz de schiste pour faire un
résumé rapide
par contre l'union européenne à des
directives sur l'environnement il ya une
loi cadre sur l'eau qui permet de savoir
effectivement de protéger les nappes
phréatiques mais aussi de savoir comment
on doit traiter l'eau qui remonte de la
fracturation hydraulique avec les
produits chimiques pour l'instant cette
eau n'a pas de statut est ce que c'est
un déchet est ce que ces lots là il va
bien falloir qu'on lui donne un statut
comment protéger l'eau qui peut être
menacé par les fourrages quel est le
statut des produits chimiques
aujourd'hui qui sont mis dans la
fracturation parce que les entreprises
ne les ont jamais déclaré dans le cas de
la directive reach sur les produits
chimiques comme rentrant dans un
processus minier donc là encore il va
falloir qu'ils aient une adaptation en
gros on ne peut pas faire de législation
globale mais on peut agir sur des petits
bouts en fait de la politique c'est ça
que vous êtes en train de nous dire
effectivement il faut que puisque c'est
une nouvelle technologie qui se met en
place que la législation européenne dans
ses différentes formes puisse
effectivement être adaptés et à se
contrôler alors justement à ce propos
nous voyons dans le reportage c'est ce
jeune homme qui essaye de mettre en
place des thermes
il a une question à vous poser on écoute
monsieur bové je suis très inquiet en ce
qui concerne le gaz de schiste dans mon
pays je trouve que le débat en france
est très positif et que les solutions
apportées à ces questions sont très
bonnes est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer
à bruxelles et aux euros parlementaire
polonais en quoi consiste la loi
française
il faut vraiment tout faire pour que
cette loi soit appliquée en pologne
josé bové quels moyens vous avez on vous
interpelle la directement quels moyens
vous avez d'agir sur ces questions est
de dupliquer pourquoi pas le modèle
français à l'étranger
le premier moyen cdg d'arrivée
interpellé la commission pour obliger la
commission
d'abord elle a fait une étude ce qui est
remarquable deux études sur les risques
environnementaux liés à la fracturation
hydraulique et au gaz de schiste donc ça
la commission a fait ce travail déjà
maintenant il faut qu'il aille plus loin
la question de la fracturation
hydraulique reste un problème il n'y a
pas de techniques alternatives
donc effectivement c'est ya trop
d'enjeux existe de la recherche et du
développement il ya déjà des projets qui
sont financés le rapport gallois
d'ailleurs qui prévoit 2 pourquoi pas ça
ne donne pas du coup mettre de côté la
question du gaz de schiste disait il
faut quand même essayer de trouver une
solution pour explorer cette voie là
mais il ya des solutions pour l'instant
il n'y a aucune solution à 10 ans 15 ans
peut-être il y aura une solution
donc ça c'est un vrai premier problème
deuxième problème qui est lié à l'europe
c'est que aujourd'hui l'europe s'est
engagée dans le cas du programme 20 20
dans le jargon repères à réduire de 30%
ses émissions de co2 par rapport au
réchauffement climatique
or on sait aujourd'hui que le méthane
qui est un gars qui est le gaz qui sort
donc des puits de fracturation
hydraulique est 30 fois plus dangereux
pour la planète en termes de
réchauffement dia qu'il y ait 30 fois
plus efficace pour réchauffer la planète
que le co2 donc là on a un vrai problème
donc aujourd'hui la question principale
c'est comment va-t-on faire parce que
la banque mondiale vient d'annoncer
dimanche 18 novembre que si ça continue
et c'est +4 degrés d'ici 2060
combattants donc on a à la fois les
questions de technique les questions
environnementales et la question
climatique pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons il faut arrêter c'est pour ça
qu'on a les moyens josé bové est
d'arrêter ça on est quand même dans une
période où l'indépendance énergétique
est une question cruciale
on voudrait sortir du nucléaire on en a
pas les moyens la transition énergétique
coûte extrêmement cher
est-ce qu'on a les moyens objectivement
de se passer d'une ressource comme le
gaz de schiste les etats unis sont
aujourd'hui indépendant alors
aujourd'hui on nous annonce une année
penche pour les étayer
j'ai envie de dire pour combien d'années
et à quel coût environnemental
mais même sociale parce que je ne suis
pas sûr que ça va durer et là j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans une bulle
spéculative des sciences les ressources
qui restent en pologne nous avait
annoncé effectivement 5000 trilliard on
en est à sept cents aujourd'hui
réellement a priori potentiel avec un co
extraordinaire aux états unis on n'est
pas du tout dans les mêmes couches
géologiques qu'on est beaucoup plus haut
donc ça coûte moins cher à exploiter
mais même pour cela je suis pas sûr que
ça va durer plus de dix ou quinze ans
donc je ne suis pas sûr que c'est une
quelque chose sur le long terme qui va
fonctionner deuxième problème c'est que
si on investit là on n'investit pas sur
le renouvelable
ça veut dire qu'on enclenche pas dès
aujourd'hui la reconversion énergétique
or ce que dit le giec est ce que reprend
aussi la crise qu'on pense au chi maïs
que reprend la banque mondiale c'est
qu'il faut que le pic de la pollution
des émissions de co2 soit atteint en
2020 un cap à 2020 on régresse pour ne
pas franchir la barre des deux degrés
d'augmentation de la température
sans quoi on va vers des catastrophes
donc il faut savoir si on est capable de
faire ce saut et c'est pour ça que dans
le cadre des financements européens
on lui il faut lancer un grand programme
énergétique mais transversale entre les
pays pas simplement par pays par pays
pour interconnecter évidemment les
réseaux mais pour produire de
renouvelables et surtout pour aller
qu'on lutter contre le gaspillage
dernière question josé bové rapidement
est ce que si on trouve un moyen demain
d'extraire le gaz de schiste de manière
propre
est ce que vous dites banques où on y va
non je dirais non parce que en raison
des émissions de méthane
on n'est pas capable de maîtriser le
méthane qui sort entre 4 et 8% du
méthane qui sort d'un puits par dans
l'atmosphère quoi qu'on fasse donc
réchauffe réchauffe l'atmosphère et je
crois que là véritablement aujourd'hui
vaut dire stop ça devient un enjeu
mondial
merci josé bové pour ses explications
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
à bruxelles
d'ici là bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires